aunque las calles de la ciudad de mexico
se pinten de naranja como lo prevé la
tradición la capital vivirá este año una
celebración del día de muertos insólita
pues diferente va a ser diferente porque
en casa los empresa limos nos
disfrazábamos fiestas todos los seis
pues ahorita nos a poder pero entonces
algo que pasajeros pero se aproximan y
se puede hacer y yo lo único que vamos a
hacer es esperar a que pase la pandemia
ella saca en efecto del 31 de octubre al
2 de noviembre los casi 120 panteones
del área metropolitana de la capital
permanecerán cerrados para impedir
aglomeraciones ante la pandemia de ccoo
y 19 lo que ha llevado a los mexicanos a
honrar sus difuntos con antelación pues
sí es triste para mucha gente que un
ejemplo nosotros que vimos que nada más
cada año y de repente el día que vamos a
venir no lo podemos hacer pues no nos
nos hace justo el gobierno creo que se
equivocan un al cementerio sólo dejan
entrar un máximo de tres personas por
familia lo que significa que los más de
700.000 turistas nación
e internacionales que inundan
habitualmente los cementarios tampoco
podrán admirar esa celebración
catalogada como patrimonio cultural
inmaterial de la humanidad por la unesco
corremos mucho riesgo entonces está bien
que nos hayan permitido venir a dejarles
nuestro nuestras flores
plantas están nuestras muertos y sobre
todo pues acompañadas a undiano la
alcaldesa de la ciudad de méxico claudia
james bond que dio positivo en la prueba
de ccoo y 19 esta semana instó a la
población a celebrar el día de muertos
en casa y por otra parte durante estas
fiestas
el gobierno mexicano decretará tres días
de luto nacional por los fallecidos de
ccoo y 19